let's go everybody welcome back to
another episode of awesome build
unfortunately I don't have a ton of time
today only about an hour to despair
but I wanted to get around to doing
another fan request for this Halloween
so I have an idea
sort of so let's go over to the
workbench and get started let's go
alright so as I said I don't have a ton
of time today but I did want to get
around to doing another one of your fan
requests and seeing as how it's still
Halloween I wanted to keep in the
Halloween theme so I had quite a few
requests to do a freddy glove from The
Nightmare on Elm Street movies I felt
like it was something you could easily
buy at a Halloween store I've seen
different gloves and they're usually
pretty decent yeah I don't own one and
I've never actually gotten one for a
costume myself I feel like they're
usually pretty well made I don't know
I'm sure they come in different
variations so kind of prompted me
there's a Halloween store right down the
street so I ran down there to see what
they had and they had two kinds and one
of them was pretty good it was about 20
or 25 bucks and you know the paint job
was was was okay but overall it was made
out of a pretty decent plastic the glove
was in not horrible but better than
other ones and the other version they
had was this woman and one for about
nine bucks or ten bucks and 99.99 a
pretty hand glove it's pretty crappy
it's super cheap plastic you can tell is
super cheap and flimsy the glove is
garbage paint job is terrible almost
non-existent so my idea is because I
have such a limited amount of time I
thought I would see if I could take this
crappy Nightmare on Elm Street glove and
make it look passable maybe even movie
quality we'll see
in order to do that definitely going to
have to discard the glove all together
and it's going to need a new paint job
I'm hoping that just the paint job and
the glove will be enough to kind of sell
it so I got a double pair of work gloves
that I don't mind cutting up to actually
already kind of falling apart and some
paint and it's about it I don't think
I'm going to make too many other
alterations to it I might do a little
bit to kind of sharpen up the blades a
little bit to kind of make them at least
look like they're sharp or pointy and
not rounded off and stuff so but yeah so
we're just going to dive right into it
and see answer right off the bat let's
open this sucker up alright so here it
is yeah as I said the the glove itself
is really bad shape
it's a
but I know actually the plastic I mean
the plastic is really cheap too but it's
not as bad as I thought but I would
definitely have to get rid of it
start over with the glove plastic is
super flimsy which is fine because the
blades should look thin and like their
actual blades so yeah let's get let's
get crackin let's see what we can't put
together in about an hour all right so
we need the right hand here
actually let's get a little warm in here
all right so as I said this gloves kind
of already kind of falling apart you've
got to cut out the palm cut some holes
in the fingers and stuff like that so
let's get cutting actually first of all
there's a lining in there get rid of the
lining altogether
yeah all right so using my razor knife I
just cut out the areas that I wanted to
remove from the glove to make it kind of
match her a little closer to Freddie's
glove the palm was all cut out and then
there's about two to three kind of holes
cut out per finger so
using the knife and the scissors kind of
cut out making sure cannot cut to the
other side and if that look clean it
could look like it was cut kind of curly
and all kind of adds to the effect
so we're all done with that I'm going to
cut out the nylon glove that the
Halloween store version came with
and make sure it fits on that glove
pretty good yeah that's good
then I give the whole thing a coat
krylon flat black
of course once I did that I realized I
forgot to sharpen or shape the blades
and make them look like they were sharp
so then I went ahead and gave it a coat
of krylon metallic is kind of a gold
finish
and then once that dried I went over it
with just a light dusting of Kryolan red
oxide and that gives it kind of that
worn a little bit more copper or brass
sort of look
I used some old modeling things I think
that Citadel games workshop modeling
paint and that's a copper finish
it's went over the whole thing
I did several passes and then wipe it
down with the paper towel
this gives it a little bit more of an
uneven kind of quality like its aging
over time
once one layer would dry I would go over
it again do the same thing
then finally I just use the flat black
paint and a watered down do a wash kind
of getting all the little nooks and
crannies and stuff like that it would
really make it kind of pop and make all
the elements look like it's old and
greasy and dirty its metallic elements
definitely more pop so there's our
crappy glow that we started with and
that's what we ended up with also after
the footage you're about to see it's the
exit video as you can see on the end
here with my explanation it definitely
looks a little shinier a little cleaner
I wanted to do a little bit more and
dirty it up so so basically this is the
final product
hi sis what we're left with oh no I
think it turned out pretty good
it definitely has more of a brass or
copper kind of a look at least it looks
more metallic I think I would probably
still dirty it up a little bit I
probably do another wash and then the
the blades I just gave a dusting of a
metallic so it's still a little bit of
black flecks that are kind of underneath
there but when the light hits it it
gives a good shine like it's actual
metal so yeah I think for about an hour
and 20 minutes most of that watching
paint dry not too bad
I think definitely looks worth a little
more than $9 or $10 at your Halloween
store so yeah go to your local thrift
store or something buy an old pair of
work gloves and cut them up they're
probably already nicely worn and look
pretty dingy you could buy a new pair
you're probably find actually a decent
pair of work gloves for like 5 or 6
bucks like leather
you know like cheaper ones or whatever
that you could cut up and stained and
dirty up and stuff like that to make
them look like Freddy's glove
I hope this satisfies those of you who
wanted to see the Freddy Krueger glove
and for those of you who like to see me
just pull objects off the shelf at a
Halloween store and repaint it and make
it look a little bit more legit
I hope this satisfies that need so
thanks for watching keep making keep
building enjoy your Halloween and I'll
see you guys next time
you